[Music]
foreign
you've heard of Colonel Walter E Kurtz
your mission is to terminate the
Colonel's command germinate
terminate
with extreme prejudice
I love the smell of napalm in the
morning
thank you
[Music]
very obviously he has gone insane
my only friend are you an assassin I'm a
soldier
around
[Music]
my only friend
welcome to Camp victory over Camp
victory that this was Camp Liberty oh no
they changed that about a week ago
Victory sound better all right
so what do you got the car has been
parked illegally
suspension is sagging there's definitely
something heavy in the trunk
interesting
what's he doing I'm gonna die I'm gonna
die comfortable
how many bombs have you disarmed 873 873
you're a wild man you know that
was too bad our first time working
together what do you think I think us
working together means I talk to you and
you talk to me you're going around Nate
Sanborn
team leader is inspiring
he's gonna get me killed
the best way to go about disarming one
of these things the way you don't dice
her
that was good
[Music]
what do we have here this box is full of
stuff it almost killed me what about
this one is this one from oil it's my
wedding ring like I said stuff that
almost killed me
[Music]
we're going on a mission
and my job is to keep you safe so we can
keep going on missions combat buddy
[Music]
you realize every time you suit up
his life or death
feeling something
you roll the dice
[Music]
and you deal with it
foreign
[Music]
my name is Lieutenant Aldo Ray
and I need me eight soldiers
we're going to be dropped into France
dressed as civilians we're going to be
doing one thing one thing only
killing Nazis yes sir members of the
National Socialist Party conquered
Europe to murder torture intimidation
and Terror and that's exactly what we're
gonna do to him we will be cruel to the
German and through our cruelty they will
know who we are
they will find the evidence of our
cruelty in the disemboweled dismembered
and disfigured bodies their brothers we
leave behind us and the German will not
be able to help themselves from
Imagining the cruelty their brothers
endured at our hands
and our boot heals
at the edge of our knives
the German will be sticking by us
the German will talk about us
and a German will fear us
Nancy ain't got no Humanity
[Music]
they need to be destroyed
each and every man under my command owes
me 100 Nancy scalps
and I want my scalps
sad good yes sir
[Music]
laughs
you have a brother in the second
Battalion if so
is he alive and with your help I'd like
to keep it that way
but they're walking into a trap
your orders are to deliver a message
calling off tomorrow morning's attack
if you don't we will lose sixteen
hundred men
your brother among them
[Music]
that is in one way this war ends
lost Man Standing
what the hell are you doing
[Music]
if you fail
it will be a massacre
[Music]
good luck
foreign
[Music]
ER
we're rich boys
get down on your knees
[__] him up
we got gold
[Music]
here was a finished Commander lost his
home and his family in the war he became
a one-man Death Squad
he's one mean [__] that you do
not want to mess with
you'll see what happens when you take
everything from him
how many Minds did you bury here all of
them
you
and you
this is not about who's the strongest
this is about not giving up
we have a word for that in Finland
[Music]
we might have a problem
the enemy tanks have stopped
why my waste precious tanks when they
can pick us off from the air like
fishing a barrel
there are four hundred thousand men on
this beach
[Music]
it's coming back round he's coming back
where are we going
Kirk
there's no hiding from this sun
we have a job to do
if we go they will die
[Music]
foreign
South Carolina the United States Marine
Corps Recruit Depot an eight-week
college for the phony tough and the
crazy Brave that is not your daddy's
shotgun cowboy
most of you will go to Vietnam some of
you will not come back Cowboy sir yes
sir on 300 infantry Joker sir yes sir
4212 basic military journalism you think
you're Mickey Spillane so I wrote for my
high school newspaper sir
thank you
I hate the name Joker I want to go up to
the field
you wasted your first day in the field
and it'd be my fault Joker you will take
off that button how's it going to look
if you get killed wearing a peace symbol
what is that you've not written on your
helmet foreign to kill sir you're right
boring to kill on your helmet and you
wear a peace button don't you love your
country yes sir why don't you jump on
the team and come on in for the big win
I'm squad leader
all right anywhere scumbag
[Music]
I need help I'm trying to help you later
are those live rounds
seven six two millimeter
[Music]
Full Metal Jacket
what the hell is your delay captain
we're waiting sir Waiting For What
private dos
who the hell is private dos
I was dreamed about being a doctor but
uh
didn't get my school
I can't stay here while all them go
fight for me but you figure this war is
just going to fit in with your ideas
while everybody else is taking life I'm
gonna be saving it that's gonna be my
way to serve
personal gift from the United
designed to bring depth to the enemy I'm
sorry Sergeant I can't touch a gun
you know quite a bit of killing does
occur in war private dos does not
believe in violence do not look to him
to save you on the battlefield
anyone else
you're saying they could go to prison I
don't know how I'm gonna live with
myself if I don't stay true to what I
believe with the world so settled
tearing itself apart
doesn't seem like such a bad thing to me
to want to put a little bit of it back
together private dust you are free to
run into the Hellfire of battle without
a single weapon to protect yourself
[Music]
I'm Gonna Get You Out
there's something you gotta see
who did this that's the card
we'll have to go back up tomorrow
and then I'm gonna go up there without
you
[Music]
help me go ahead and trust me
Lord
help me get one more
[Music]
in 1967 Oliver Stone was a combat
infantryman in Vietnam
during his tour he received a bronze
star for gallantry
Ten Years Later in Hollywood he was
picking up an Oscar for the screenplay
of Midnight Express
[Music]
now he has another story to tell a movie
that grew out of his own experience
Stone has come a long way from Vietnam
but he has not left it behind
[Music]
people say I'm the life
deep inside
[Music]
the
first real casualty of war is innocence
the first real movie about the war in
Vietnam
is platoon
foreign
this
Bridge open
winner critically acclaimed Australian
actor Kirk Lazarus underwent a
controversial procedure in order to play
the platoon's African-American Sergeant
I know who I am I'm a dude playing the
dude disguises another dude
I do
take a picture of this
I want to make this movie right you take
those boys up there and put them in the
trees ship the whole thing gorilla Style
real fair in the ride yes yes the movie
they think they're making exterior
rainforest dust cut to a frightening
jungle isn't a movie anymore
[Music]
exactly let's use it
I got speed man
some of us might not make it back what
do you mean like not on the same flight
I'll send you here
hey dude you all right totally lean into
that bro you wanna do one more
I don't believe you people what do you
mean you people
what do you mean you people
[Music]
don't make it not true
foreign
[Music]
director Stephen Spielberg comes one of
the most powerful and important films
ever made ever saves a long life Saves
the World entire
now on Blu-ray for the first time ever
Schindler's List the 20th anniversary
limited edition
I want these people these people my
people I want my people winner of seven
Academy Awards they say your factories
are Haven they say you are good who says
that everyone including best picture
the list is alive and best director
Steven Spielberg what's a person worth
no no no no no what's one worth to you
meticulously restored in high definition
600.
experience this masterpiece of cinematic
history that will be Generations because
of what you did
[Music]
Schindler's List own the 20th
anniversary limited edition on Blu-ray
high definition
thank you
let me ask you a question Chris
would you be surprised if I told you
that the Navy has credited you with over
160 kills
do you ever think that you might have
seen things
or done some things over there that you
wish you had
oh that's not me you know
what's not you
[Music]
I don't tell you enough I'm so proud of
you
under such a great father
so you're not worried about what might
happen
[Music]
I'm willing to meet my creator
and ask for every shot that I took
I'll pick it up
drop it
so what are you in Germany or where I'm
Stateside you're home
what what are you doing
I guess I just needed a minute
[Music]
[Applause]
the thing that haunts me are all the
guys that I couldn't say
hey my daughter please right now
[Applause]
I'm ready
[Music]
oh my God
I'm ready to come home
[Music]
you shouldn't have come here
this is our wolf
[Music]
genocide
these people they have no proof we can
either help or we can sit back and watch
a country destroy itself on CNN Rangers
Deltas today we go man Blackburn date of
birth
227-75. I was trying to fight he's
trying to fight Sergeant Kyle was trying
to make a difference so guess what
you're going out today what it's what
you wanted isn't it oh yeah
[Music]
hell yeah just remember when everybody
else is shooting and shooting the same
direction
all right
[Music]
you ever shot on anybody before no sorry
me neither
once that first bullet goes past your
head
politics go right out the window
hey baby it's me you're there pick up if
you're there
I love you baby
I need help now
where's the rescue squad we're it
I can't do it it's what you do right now
that makes a difference
[Music]
people ask me why do you do it man they
won't understand it's about the man next
to you don't let that man crawl somebody
help that
that's all it is
[Music]
nobody has to be a hero
sometimes turns out that way
[Music]
they are the world's greatest
Mercenaries
the only life they've ever known is war
the only loyalty they've ever had
is to each other
[Applause]
but the four on the left why don't you
take the two in the right and leave the
rest not the first anymore oh here we go
the only thing faster light exactly
we'll see
foreign
first the only thing you need to know is
the job's real and the money's real
with this job to my friend here he loves
playing in the jungle right right it's
his problem
follow me please
people who fight back are killed now we
have a dying place maybe you can help I
don't think so probably I'd leave
[Music]
what do we got four and a Half Men
that's so funny
you know it's not easy being your friend
we will kill this American this
[Music]
I promised myself I'm gonna die for
something counts
people live for terrible times but you
must believe you can survive
ten seconds you won't believe what's
gonna happen
thank you
what happened to you got my ass kicked
[Music]
are you crazy could it kill me you're
welcome
I promise
[Music]
John you have tallies approaching
you still remember a thing I don't
remember any of it
I only remember
The Interpreter
[Music]
why he wants this job I need the money
don't disappoint turn out to be a pain
in the ass no not me sir
money isn't the reason he wants his job
and Taliban killed his son
you don't want to go down this road
you're out of your bounds Ahmed you're
here to translate actually I'm here to
interpret John you have Tally's
approaching
for three weeks this family believed you
are dead we owe that man your life if it
wasn't enough for him to carry me across
those mountains
[Music]
no he's hiding in a hole somewhere I
should be in that hole
everything all right John no
everything's not all right there is a
hook in me Ahmed and his family are in
trouble we can't intervene
I am going to see bad amount myself
listen You're Gonna Be Alone
is what you got
if you can give me the location if I can
get them out of the country it's too
dangerous
to become very popular with the Taliban
I miss you love you Daddy
if I could be free of this debt I
wouldn't be
you'd think I have a choice
there is no choice
back down
do you remember what happened when
during the battle
welcome to the dark side of the moon
gentlemen
aren't we supposed to be on top of the
mountain to win this thing
[Music]
our job is to separate the Taliban and
the Ordinary People
how do we do our jobs and stay safe
respect keeps us safe I wouldn't trade
this for anything look at us Band of
Brothers give me your prayers okay
trust me babe I quit I love you I'm
gonna win by getting their hearts of
mine we want the hearts and minds and
they want our blood and Gus
sorry pal but that's life of Camp
kidding
every time they take a pot shot at us
they're figuring us out
and the big one comes
I love us dialed in
what calibers are here
it's the big one Saddle Up Everybody
fall back enemy in The Wire
I'll hang back and provide cover
we need to retake this camp we don't
have any air support the Manpower our
men are trapped out there
our ammo deeper was 40 yards away
there's everything we need to stay in
this fight
Sarah
[Music]
let's show them some love with the 120s
you're right
drums around me you're not gonna die
okay
[Music]
this [__] back
foreign
this is Colonel Powell she's going to
walk you through the capture of Aisha
al-hadi AKA Susan Danford
we have intelligence of a meeting
between Danford and numbers four and
five on our most wanted list
[Music]
we have information that they will be in
this house today
this is an operation to capture not kill
Ed range 22 000 feet you have your
orders Lieutenant your job is to be
there Eye in the Sky yes ma'am I have to
know if Stanford is inside and who is
with her
[Music]
that's Stanford
well this changes things
what's happening being a suicide person
a whole bunch of explosives what's the
plan General we have the ability to
strike a target with considerable
accuracy okay
lives are at stake if these men leave we
need to put a Hellfire through that roof
right now
given the new circumstances I think you
should have bought you have number four
and five on the president's kill list in
your sights and you are putting the
whole mission at risk because of one
collateral damage issue
minister
we are locked into this kill chain I
need legal clearance to strike I'm the
piloting command responsible for
releasing weapon Ivan fire when this
girl's out of the way there is a lot
more at stake than you see in this image
they kill 80 people we win the
propaganda War if we kill one child they
do
we've got two suicide bombers inside
that house and no one wants to take
responsibility for pulling the trigger
we need a decision ready right now three
go two wait one
[Music]
thank you
dear Lord let your Holy Angel be with me
that the Evil film may have no power
over thank you
into your hands I commend myself my body
and soul amen
congratulations on your command
I'll always be looking for you Evie even
if I'm a thousand miles away
air escort to Greyhound you will now be
on a range of air cover for the next
five days safe travels to England
Crossings does this make this is my
first
I got some most likely to you both
lost fire
we have a kill
[Applause]
the stress rocket sir
we have hits directly on the Convoy the
wolf bags
[Music]
in 48 hours we've lost seven ships
dissolves
what you did yesterday
it's not enough
I'm not nearly enough
[Applause]
[Music]
targets disappeared sir
[Applause]
oh
here they come
what are we gonna do we'll bring hell
down from on high
can I be honest with you
I am bad news
I'm not your friend
I'm not gonna help you
[Music]
I'm gonna break you
any questions
Maya this is Joseph Bradley our station
Chief nice to meet you sir
you don't think she's a little young for
the hard stuff
Washington says she's a killer
I want to make something clear we're
spending billions of dollars
we're still no closer to defeating our
enemy
20 detainees recognize that photo no
birth certificate no cell phone you guys
ghost
do it
you really believe this story
Osama bin Laden yeah what convinced you
her confidence
this is a professional attempt to avoid
detection real trade craft
run a list you of all people should know
that once you're on their list
there's a 60 probability he's there sir
[Music]
100 percent
I know certainty freaks you guys out but
it's a hundred
he's one of the Disappeared ones
[Music]
thank you
help me down
[Music]
Middle School
thank you
[Music]